hey guys it's Jonah here and still in
Greece enjoy my early summer holiday
plus working at the same time the sun is
shining really bright so we want to do
another Beachbody workout series this
time we want to focus on our apps when
you have a strong core you will have a
stronger body but the posture and also
better balance we want to do the
workouts back-to-back without any rest
for 30 seconds each
grab your yoga mat and be sure to
complete these very effective exercises
before the end of your workout session
so let's do it we'll be doing 4
exercises so the first workout is going
to be half be touched
ok so I want you to just place your
elbows on the floor keep your toes
pointed legs straight and just keep your
leg straight and go up and down all
right so this workout it's really
popular among gymnast right so take a
short breather in 5 seconds we will be
doing together 30 seconds each workout
down and let's go up really crunch and
few your low apps down and up nice leg
straight and really feel your lower abs
working and your upper abs tightening up
as well ok so your upper body should
just be relaxed it should just be
supporting you and just relax your
shoulders go up really crunch and feel
your lower abs down and up nice keep
going
five more seconds left nice and the next
workout will be Russian twist so just
down set up keep your legs together cook
them and just twist touch right to side
nice there you go well I can feel the
sun shining right in my face I want you
to just look the up a bit side and just
touch side to side very good twist as
much as you can and get your core body
straight do not hunch keep going and the
next workout will be pull in to downward
dog
ok good so now I want you to get into a
plank position
cross over to downwards dog cross just
on one side nice so we're gonna left
right
Nik and cross crunch and push it up so
really extend your lower back and
through your back stretch out nice keep
going
focusing on one side stretch and stretch
and the final workout will be plank hip
drop so into a plank position just drop
your hip side to side and I want you to
touch the floor tap the floor gently and
come back down okay so not too high
maintain a low plank level good keep
going nice tap really go and really
twist and feel your hips working your
abs working and your Blix working five
more seconds good keep going and you
would get a thirty Seconds rest good job
well done
rest for a short while and we want to
repeat the entire workout once more so
take a breather short breather remember
the first workout will be half V tucks
okay and remember point your toes keep
your knees straight keep your leg
straight and really work on your lower
abs and also tighten your upper abs
right now down two seconds Lix up let's
go up and down nice straight legs up and
down
crunch nice nice and controlled crunch
really engage and feel your abs your
legs shaping okay those shakes are good
so really work on them nice keep going
there you go crunch and really control
it down don't just drop it control it
down and remember the second workout
will be Russian twist good without
stopping one more and Russian tweet legs
up cross over just gently twist and
touch nice twist and touch look straight
ahead if you want to all look the
opposite direction good twist and touch
and next will be cross over to downward
dog ten seconds
just let your legs really engage your
core to keep your body up right three
seconds very good and now let's go left
legs cross over and downward dog three
stretch out cross and nice go elbow to
knee and stretch good you can also feel
your butt muscles being stretched out
and working together very good so your
core isn't just your abs but it's really
about working your lower back as well
and let's get straight into plank hip
drop so remember go really low and tap
side to side good job there you go tap
tap tap keep your feet together and
remain a nice low plank and really
tighten that engage your core to feel
your abs working and feel your lower
back as well this is your final workout
and you will get a good well-deserved
rest
and now just pull in and stretch it out
so that was a very quick five-minute ab
workout to work on your entire
midsection your lower abs your upper abs
your lower back and also your obliques
if you want to challenge yourself of
course you can repeat the entire workout
once more for a total of four sets for
best result combine this workout
together with total body strength
training and also cardio and don't
forget to do this workout at the end of
each workout session okay and I can
assure you you will is body fat and also
gain a flatter tummy if you enjoy this
workout and be sure to share it as well
all the best if you're passionate about
healthy living and want to help others
to get active then sign up to the
National Academy of Sports Medicine
online personal training costs they are
currently offering a 14-day free trial
and you'll get to learn everything from
creating exercise programs food
nutrition and skills to succeed in the
industry so click on the link in my
description box for more information and
share this